um
pretty [ __ ] music pretty [ __ ] music is
it done
it's it's done it's done but this is my
album it's done-ish it's done-ish yeah
so like you know it's done but
the right record comes uh comes around
and you can still make the album exactly
features are already turned in no not
yet I like working with artists like in
person like I got to work with Rico
nasty dreezy
um
and a couple more other people I'm like
an in-person type of collaborator I
don't like sending it back and forth
yeah I feel like that's a lost art form
too because nobody's getting in no more
they just send emails yeah crazy super
dope I love her yeah we gotta um a song
called Bay cargo
Bay cargo mm-hmm I like I like that you
actually do an album called Bay cargo
[ __ ] it
would you a joint album with somebody I
would do a joint album with dreezy yeah
that'd be fire she's hard I just was
telling my team
Dan when you gonna put this out I want
to tell her before this thing comes out
I just saw her last night and it was
hella loud so I was like I got an idea
for us because she asked me about the
song but I've been wanting to like
collaborate with another woman and I
really like dreezy yeah she's dope her
and uh hit boy put out a a super fire
project uh yeah and I think that's dope
too because I feel like um I just think
it's good to see
um
like a artist just working with each
other especially in a female space you
know absolutely pulling each other up
yeah being a fan like I feel like that's
like back to the double standard thing
but remember the fan of a fan with Chris
and tiger oh yeah it was like love
support fine you know gotta get back to
that oh the Tisa Snapback days do you
remember those hats was it that's that
right
I don't know tiger had those [ __ ]
snapbacks booming boy it was that was
such a I remember just watching like
that era in LA and that's what made me
really want to come to L.A because I was
in San Diego and I would come to La
every weekend on the um what is the
Amtrak every weekend